from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between burger king in india and the us
this is food wars
[Music]
in burger king india our drinks come in
one standard size which looks to be your
small or medium but you can also opt for
a can of 330 ml burger king in the us
our drinks come in four sizes value
small
medium
and large
let's measure this cup to see how much
is actually in here does it make anybody
else want to pee
or is it just me
34 ounces what's this 38 at the bottom
of the cup it ain't 38. our burger king
fries come in two sizes medium and king
our fries come in four sizes value small
medium large
i remember the large being bigger than
this i'm just glad that the fuss we rose
for the first uk us
food wars burger king has
resulted fry transparency next up
chicken fries i didn't know this was a
thing so i'm very excited to eat them it
should have five pieces three
four
five
six
thank you burger king
oh never mind one of the fries had
broken they gave me five ours also is
one size nine chicken fries
it's like a pack of chicken cigarettes
seven eight nine a nice brown on brown
yeah we thought ahead for this one the
next one we shoot them i'm wearing all
brown or a brown jumpsuit we're gonna
paint this brown the most unwatchable
series
here's everything you'll find on the
menu at burger king india that you won't
find in the u.s and here's everything
you can get at a u.s burger king you
can't get in india let's begin with the
whoppers this is a good time to mention
that here in india most fast food
restaurants do not serve beef or pork to
keep the religious sentiments of both
hindus and muslims conservative hindus
will not enter a restaurant that serves
beef conservative muslims might not
enter a restaurant that serves pork all
right keeping all of that in mind let us
begin with the chicken whopper oh
boy okay burger king definitely has
larger burgers than most of the
restaurants here in india look at this
it's the size of my face i am the burger
king
that's so good you might notice if you
are a regular burger king consumer of
the foreign lands that if you were to
eat this one
it's a little spicier and i think
they've done that because most indians
love their spice there's a lot of bite
to it next up double chicken patty whoa
whoa whoa whoa this one's got some heft
to it huh the mutton hopper mutton if
you are unaware is goat meat and burger
king is one of the few fast food chains
here that actually serves red meat of
some kind indians love their mutton i
love my mutton
it's definitely more meaty has a lot
more bite to it than the chicken god
birding what are you doing the quality
is out of control
every beef burger at burger king is a
u.s exclusive got all the whoppers let's
start down here the little guy the
whopper a junior
not enough meat you say get yourself a
double whopper same burger two patties
can they go bigger they can the
triple whopper look at this thing
hey
close your mouth while you're taking a
picture
the texans of the audience might have to
help us out in the comments here the
texas double whopper texas prides itself
from what i can tell i know he's going
bigger so why wouldn't it be the texas
triple whopper a rare moment where texas
was reserved
texans of the internet i think you guys
need to step in here i don't think that
sandwich is doing you guys proud on to
the wedge options this is a veg whopper
i expect great things from this bad boy
i would say this is pretty lackluster
next up veggie double burger
if you want double the disappointment
another thing that we have that
technically isn't beef is the impossible
whopper which is made with impossible
beef i'm actually very curious how does
the impossible burger patty taste joe
regular beef
i have the ham too it tastes exactly the
same i want to give the environment a
break maybe get one of these every once
in a while next up we have an exclusive
king collection of burgers these better
be uh quite royal and aristocratic
number one hot and cheesy veg
a lot of
jalapenos
the patty actually has like cheese melt
in it hot and cheesy king's collection
on a scale of common villager to the
king himself i would rate this
village bard once in a while you want
him there just to appease a few people
but otherwise
pretty lackluster paneer royal
just by the name itself
this one
should be incredible so paneer if you
don't know is cottage cheese and here in
india it is almost a staple we eat it
and everything we eat in curries we
sometimes just sear it and eat it plain
and obviously it had to make its way to
burgers
the paneer is really good chewy and
delicious i would rate the paneer royal
a local baron helps the king around a
little bit now on to the two non-veg
options we have fiery chicken food plain
and simple they just want this meat to
blow my mind
it's just spicy that's all it is it
doesn't have the depth of flavor that
the chicken whoppers did chicken
tandoori if you guys don't know what a
tandoor is it's basically this
cylindrical oven that we heat up using
wood fire and charcoal traditionally and
we use it to create everything from
kebabs to breads i doubt all burger king
outlets have an actual tandoor in their
restaurants but let's see if they were
able to replicate that smoky flavor
on a scale of absolute street urchins to
maharajas i would rate these two court
traitors
that try to backstab the king and now
they're on trial they have a lot of bark
but not enough bite they're going to be
executed soon non-whopper burgers aka
burgers get yourself something called
the big king that's what it looks like
don't have it what we do have is the
single quarter pound king bacon king
i always say generous amount of bacon
that's great then these little much more
reasonable sized burgers bacon
cheeseburger bacon double cheeseburger a
bacon free double cheeseburger right one
of the most hilarious things on the
burger king menu is of course a rodeo
burger a burger with barbecue sauce and
onion rings cause why not yeah
cheeseburger regular dry ass hamburger
who cares enough kingly sandwiches it's
now time for the regular vegetarian
options that they have we have crispy
wedge crispy wedge double crispy wedge
with cheese
bk classic bk classic with cheese light
whopper junior and light whopper junior
with cheese
why is it called light whopper junior
how many more things do you need to add
to the name to make it seem small mini
light small whopper junior
kindergartener burger how about that
next time burger king okay i don't want
to try any more veg burgers but this one
the bk classic veg seems different like
the bun
looks to be the same but they've
definitely used more perky buns here
don't use that audio clip out of context
okay
finally if you're a vegetarian
i would recommend the bk classic with
cheese
boom although it is currently for a
limited time thought i would share with
you guys here in the u.s we have the
south west options at burger king
starting with the southwest bacon junior
the southwest whopper the southwest
impossible whopper what makes it
southwest oh i'm seeing like crispy
little chippy guys oh spicy oh it's got
some heat to it yeah there's guacamole
on here hang on
what kind of [ __ ] with it i wouldn't eat
it if i didn't work at food wars you
know
and now for the chicken sandwiches these
look so tiny compared to the whoppers we
have crispy chicken crispy chicken
double crispy chicken with cheese pk
classic chicken spicy grilled chicken
big smoky grilled chicken light hopper
chicken junior light whopper double
chicken junior and light copper
chicken junior cheese
yes i could work at burger king right
now we're going to try this two of these
burgers just to see if they're any
different first one the spicy
grilled chicken
oh my god i can imagine myself going to
a drive-through taking one of these
driving to work sitting in silk traffic
getting annoyed with all the other
people honking realizing i should have
gotten a bigger burger and next day
ordering two nice
next up the big smoky
grilled chicken
i don't see how this is smoky at all in
fact it's kind of sweet and to the naan
beef options i personally think these
new chicken sandwiches are fantastic the
chick king that's ch apostrophe king
because it's burger king spicy chicken
sandwich same thing got some spicy sauce
on it this is very good if you like
these but want a little more veggies
because you're some old fogey here you
go vegetables they also make the chick
king deluxe deluxe equals lettuce and
tomato this car crash of a sandwich is
the spicy actually the spicy with
veggies is actually kind of nice the
coolness of the the lettuce and the
tomato actually counter balances the
spice the original chicken sandwich
shaped like the new iphone for some
strange reason this guy's been around
forever it's their answer to the
mcchicken it tastes exactly like in the
chicken chicken junior there's a little
guy
a spicy chicken junior and last the only
naan chicken thing in the chicken
section is the big fish
and now for a set of snacks that comes
under their stunner menu
[Music]
we have king egg burger king egg wrap
crispy veg wrap veg crunchy volcano
that's right this is not even a wrap
this is a little geological formation
tikki twist burger veg makhani burger
and chicken makhani burger and finally
crispy chicken wrap and crunch chicken
volcano all right the first burger we're
trying is the chicken makhani burger so
makhan means butter and it also means a
lot to us indians you just walk in the
room and you say makhan it will resound
through the room like people's eyes will
perk up the hairs on their arms will
rise oh my god yum
okay so they've gone for like a butter
chicken makhani flavor but it just
tastes like tomato puree over a stale
chicken patty next thing that i really
want to try is the the volcano itself
and i think this is their answer to taco
bell's crunchwrap
oh that's pretty good he was this close
to offending two communities and mother
earth herself but pretty good next thing
i'm going to try is an aloo tikki twist
tiki twist sounds like a cocktail but
aloo tikki is actually it's like mashed
potato fried with bread crumbs and it's
used in chaat it's used in a lot of
other dishes and they put these crispy
shards of what seems to be
the same material
in the volcano
illuminati confirmed
[Music]
and to breakfast
we got breakfast at the bk in the u.s
you can get an assortment of chris
sandwiches biscuits melts i didn't get
all of them starting down here a crew
sandwich of course for those who not in
america is it took a croissant
and stuff eggs and cheese and your
choice of breakfast meat bacon egg and
cheese croissant sausage egg and cheese
croissant ham egg and cheese croissants
bacon egg and cheese biscuit sausage egg
and cheese biscuit ham egg and cheese
biscuit cheesy ham breakfast melts
sausage and cheese breakfast melt cheesy
bacon breakfast and for both the chris
sandwiches and the biscuits you can also
get pretty much every combination of
meat egg and cheese on said biscuit or
sandwich egg norma's burrito ah no no no
no no i am not starting off my morning
with this no thank you this looks like a
dirty diaper like what is any of this i
feel like if i bit this in like one bite
of this in the morning and i'm on the
toilet
get yourself two platters sausage and
pancakes platter and this one i think
it's like the platter deluxe you can
sell pancakes get stuffed bacon get
yourself eggs and of course syrup next
up chicken wings burger king here sells
boneless chicken wings they feel like
chicken tenders on me
the super meaty it's like proper chicken
it's not like that processed nuggety
chicken juice thing that happens in the
u.s our burger king has nuggets and they
come in four pieces
and eight pieces
i asked the burger king employees about
the 16 piece and they said they don't
have a 16 piece they just give you two
eight pieces now it's time for burger
india's sides and sauces number one we
have the classic peri-peri fries they
give it to you with a little sashi of
the peri-peri powder and a little shake
bag pour it in there
voila your simple plain fries are now
peri-parried
hmm
[Music]
go with mcdonald's peri-peri fries i'm
sorry burger king too powdery almost
chalky and the flavor is not quite there
okay
very very prices come back with
vengeance fair enough there is a bit of
spice to it next up cheesy fries
italian cheesy fries and i don't know
what makes these italian but i think
it's a whole lot of oregano and finally
veggie strips well the bk here in the us
and get yourself onion rings
jalapeno cheddar bites see what this
looks like mozzarella stick matz
applesauce
can't have nuggets without sauces you
know what that means
sauce talk as for the dips we have easy
cheesy twisted mustard
fiery hell
they literally named one of their dips
fiery hell
first up buffalo sauce honey mustard
ranch sweet and sour zesty sauce do we
know what this is
that is just mayonnaise and like brown
mustard marinara sauce
salsa del sol
it is milkshake time burger king has
three flavors right now they have
mango
berry blast and chocolate
guys at the time of filming this it is
currently mango season here in india
none of you have tasted a real mango
until you've tasted the king of all
mangoes alfonso available here
everywhere you go right now you're going
to get a delicious mango milkshake we
also make something called amras which
is like a delicious mango
juice to eat with puris and stuff let's
see if this compares to fresh mango
juice oh
it's pretty good it's not too sweet it
just kinda tastes like mango ice cream
sort of mixed but i like it i really
like it next up berry blast paper straws
burger king thank you the dolphins
appreciate it just as much as i do
whoa i did not expect that flavor here
we have something called black currant
ice cream that's rampant in a very
demented families that order the the
black current ice cream i'm sorry to
single out these indian families like
this but this tastes like that i'm
sensing a pattern here so it won't be a
surprise to me if the chocolate
milkshake also just tastes like watered
down chocolate ice cream
the mango one i suppose if it wasn't
mango season you could go and get a
mango milkshake but otherwise go to any
other fruit or milkshake store in india
get a nice thick mango shake with actual
mangoes
way better on to the cold drinks let's
start with the shakes over here we have
a frozen coke you can also get a frozen
fanta wild cherry sounds amazing our
burger king did not have it first one is
this the oreo shake
why is that so good it's like a shake
made out of the stuff in the middle
brilliant idea and you can also get
chocolate oreo shake
no it's not this one's better this one's
very good desserts i'm a sucker for
desserts but why would you order dessert
from a fast food place unless i'm going
to be proven wrong first up they have
chocolate mousse cup okay it's got a
little bit of cake at the bottom
chocolate chocolate chocolate at the top
chocolate chips on the top
too decadent very sweet next up they
have a choco lava cup keeping in theme
with their random volcano based food
items and i'm sure this would ooze out
chocolate but you have to heat it first
that is so sweet when would i eat this
i'm trying to think of when i would eat
something this sweet
never we have three dessert exclusives
the first one is just the hershey's
sundae pie chocolate chip cookies a
soft-serve cup or cone where is it joe
well it's roughly 100 degrees here in
southern california and that thing would
have melted into a soup before even got
it to the studio imagine either a sort
of ice cream cone or a melted soft serve
ice cream cone would be more accurate as
for cold drinks we have pepsi mountain
dew mirinda which is an orange soda and
iced tea all of these are under the
pepsico range of products and of course
in india the pepsi slogan is
swag which means every sip has a lot of
swag
and i have to live with this cringe for
the rest of my life now
here in the u.s we have obviously a
variety of exclusive drinks can't get in
india
coke
dr pepper
diet coke there it is barks baby fanta
orange i should say that at least the
bks that i go to here in sunny southern
california has those coke freestyle
machines so you can also get yourself an
orange juice it's really funny looking
at orange juice next to orange drink
like look at the difference with it
orange juice orange drink capri sun
apple juice burger king iced coffee the
bk cafe which is of course coffee milk
let's talk price a single indian chicken
whopper will cost you 199 rupees or 1.56
u.s dollars at current conversion rates
in the u.s a whopper costs 8.79
or
668 indian rupee that's around a 236
percent increase in price make it a meal
with medium fries and a large drink and
it'll cost you 383 rupees or 5.03 us
dollars add a medium fry and a medium
drink to the order and that brings a
price to 16.37
or
1246 indian rupee again about a 225
increase now upgrade to the large size
and it's 407 rupees or 5.35 us dollars
make it a large 16.77
or
1276 indian rupee it's a 214 percent
increase 200 rupees for a single burger
is actually very expensive and while
fast food in the u.s and other foreign
countries might seem like something that
the average person can easily afford
here in india this is expensive and only
the upper middle class and the rich can
actually go out and have a burger like
this in fact in mumbai where we're
filming this right now our most popular
street food is vada pa which is like a
potato burger and it cost us 15 rupees
which is 20 cents it can fill you up
downgrade the cost upgrade the taste get
a vada pop to better illustrate the
price difference let's compare the u.s
large hopper combo to our combination of
two whoppers two crispy chicken
sandwiches five piece chicken strips
king fries and four drinks
all of this still costs less at just 1
102 rupees or 14.45
us dollars we would have to add a crispy
wedge with cheese and a crispy chicken
with cheese to get around the same price
but again i have to remind you that in
14 an average family here in india could
eat at home for a week
calories time my favorite part of these
videos because i realize
how much i should not be eating this
food let's start off with the crispy
chicken sandwich from burger king
it has 430 calories and in the u.s our
crispy chicken sandwich is 670 calories
next up is one of burger king india's
most popular burgers the wedge whopper
at
728 calories
imagine that high calories low taste
we don't have that but in the us our
burger king does have the impossible
whopper which contains 630 calories next
let's compare the fries an average box
of king sized fries will cost you 535
calories
if i had to choose between these fries
and an hour of cycling
let's be real i'd probably skip the
cycling but
this is still bad it's a lot of calories
and in the us a large fry has 430
calories and now for some reason if
you're really looking to pack on those
calories introducing burger king india's
most calorific sandwich the masala
wedge hopper
at a total of
734
calories yeah yeah the website of burger
king india also says they sell a 15
piece grilled chicken wings with a total
of
1256 calories but we called a bunch of
stores it was unavailable and i think
they discontinued it because they did
not want to kill half the country oh yo
yeah this is definitely
a block of calories and the usbk our
most calorific sandwich is this
the bacon king just one of these bad
boys 1
359 calories
oof
god damn it brown on brown on brown
brown on brown on brown brown brown
brown brown brown
hey you got to handle these fast food
companies man they make the [ __ ] look
real appetizing for what is literally
how many different shades of brown